>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING
AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WHAT IF SOMEONE YOU HATED
OFFERED TO PAY OFF YOUR
MORTGAGE, PUT YOUR KIDS THROUGH
COLLEGE, DELIVER A
TRACTOR-TRAILER FULL OF SNICKERS
BARS TO YOUR HOUSE.
YOU'D BE CONFUSED AT FIRST AND
SUSPICIOUS.
WHY IS AN ENEMY GIVING YOU THE
GIFT OF A LIFETIME?
IN THE END, IF YOU WERE SMART,
YOU WOULD TAKE THE GIFTS.
IT WOULD BE TOO GOOD TO PASS UP.
SOMETHING VERY MUCH LIKE THAT
HAPPENED IN WASHINGTON LAST
NIGHT FOR "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN DEBATING
MOVING SOME OF THE THOUSANDS OF
MIGRANTS AMASSING ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER INTO VARIOUS
SELF-PROCLAIMED CENTURY CITIES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES BY THE
PRESIDENT LATER CONFIRMED THAT
AS TRUE IN A TWEET AS OF
TONIGHT.
THAT POLICY REMAINS UNDER
CONSIDERATION.
TALK ABOUT GREAT NEWS FOR BLUE
AMERICA!
THE LEFT LOVES IMPOVERISHED
AMERICANS FROM THE DEVELOPING
WORLD, WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
THEY MAKE OUR CITIES SAFER, THEY
TELL US WHERE THEY IMPROVE OUR
SCHOOLS, THEY PROVIDE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY, THEY DO
THE WORK WE WANT TO DO.
THEY ARE DIVERSE, THEY ARE OUR
STRENGTH.
THEY ARE THE BEST OF AMERICA,
EVEN THOUGH TECHNICALLY THEY ARE
NOT AMERICAN.
CENTURY CITIES LOVE THEM BEST OF
ALL.
THAT'S WHY THEY BECOME
SANCTUARIES FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
EVERY DEMOCRAT NOW RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT HAS AFFIRMED THIS
REPEATEDLY.
>> WOULD YOU TAKE THE WALL DOWN
NOW HERE?
>> YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> OFFER A HOME FOR REFUGEES BUT
THAT IS WHO WE ARE.
THAT'S OUR VALUES.
THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE DO.
>> SO INSTEAD OF BUILDING A WALL
OR CLOSING THE BORDER, WE SHOULD
CHOOSE COMPASSION INSTEAD OF
CRUELTY.
>> WE WELCOME REFUGEES AND BRING
PEOPLE OUT OF        OUT OF THES
PEOPLE OUT OF        OUT OF THEA
PEOPLE OUT OF        OUT OF THEO
PEOPLE OUT OF        OUT OF THES
PEOPLE OUT OF        OUT OF THE.
>> IMMIGRATION IS NOT A SECURITY
ISSUE.
IT IS ECONOMIC AND HUMANITARIAN
AND A FAMILY ISSUE.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS AN
ILLEGAL HUMAN.
>> Ed: "THERE IS NO SUCH THING
AS AN ILLEGAL HUMAN."
GOOD POINT, KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND!
WE APPRECIATE YOUR ELOQUENCE.
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF
BELIEVES THAT SO DEEPLY THAT
LAST YEAR SHE WARNED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN HER CITY,
INCLUDING SEVERAL CRIMINALS,
THAT AN I.C.E. RAID WAS COMING.
SHE WANTED TO GIVE THEM TIME TO
FLEE AND SHE DID.
AS SHE LATER EXPLAINED, SHE SAID
SHE HAD NO CHOICE.
ALL GOOD PEOPLE WANT MORE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THEIR
CITIES.
>> IT IS A CONTINUED
PERPETUATION OF A RACIST LIE
THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT VALUED
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY.
WE IN OAKLAND KNOW BETTER.
WE IN OAKLAND HAVE A COMMUNITY
THAT WELCOMES AND HONORS ALL
PEOPLE NO MATTER WHERE THEY CAME
FROM OR HOW THEY GOT HERE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE WELCOMING.
IN FACT THE WHOLE STATE IS
WELCOMING.
IN THE INAUGURAL ADDRESS, THE
INCOMING GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
ECHOED THOSE WORDS, EVERYONE CAN
COME TO CALIFORNIA, HE SAID.
ABSOLUTELY EVERYONE.
>> WE NEED TO BUILD A HOUSE
STRONGER THAN THE COMING STORMS,
A HOUSE THAT PROVIDE SHELTER TO
ALL WHO NEED IT AND SANCTUARY TO
ALL WHO SEEK IT.
WE WILL NOT HAVE ONE HOUSE FOR
THE RICH, AND ONES FOR THE POOR,
OR ONES FOR THE NATIVE-BORN AND
ONE FOR THE REST.
>> Tucker: THE LEFT REALLY
COULDN'T BE CLEARER ON THIS
QUESTION.
ALL IMMIGRATION IS GOOD.
MORE IMMIGRATION IS BETTER.
THERE IS NO DISTINCTION BETWEEN
LEGAL AND ILLEGAL VARIETIES OF
IMMIGRATION.
AND IF YOU DISAGREE WITH ANY OF
THIS, YOU ARE A WHITE
NATIONALIST.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY ALMOST
EVERY DAY FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS
BUT WE WATCH CAREFULLY, SO HAVE
YOU.
NOW HERE, COMPLETELY OUT OF THE
BLUE, COMES THE MAN THEY DESPISE
THE MOST IN THE WORLD, DONALD J.
TRUMP, OFFERING THE ONE THING
THEY WANT MORE THAN ANYTHING,
MORE IMMIGRANTS.
IMMEDIATELY DELIVERED RIGHT TO
THEIR DOOR AT FEDERAL EXPENSE.
IT MUST'VE BEEN LIKE CHRISTMAS
MORNING.
YOU THINK YOU ARE GETTING
ANOTHER PAIR OF SOCKS, YET THERE
IT IS.
A PONY TETHERED TO YOUR MAILBOX.
HOLY SMOKES, AMAZING.
BEST DAY OF YOUR LIFE.
THAT'S NOT HOW THEY RESPONDED.
THE LEFT WASN'T HAPPY ABOUT
TRUMP'S OFFER.
THEY WERE SHOCKED, THEY WERE
COMPLETELY ENRAGED.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS, THEY
SAID?
IT'S "DUMPING."
DUMPING.
LIKE YOU DO WITH GARBAGE OR USED
TRUCK TIRES IN THE WOODS.
THEY HAD LINE OF "MOTHER JONES"
RED, DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO DUMP
ASYLUM-SEEKERS ON THE STREET OF
AMERICAN CITIES.
DEMOCRATIC CITIES.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" GREG
MILLER, DUMP THEM ON THE CITIES
TO PUNISH POLITICAL RIVALS.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTED TO "DUMP
REFUGEES IN REFUGEE CITIES.
PEOPLE CAUGHT THAT NASTY.
ALMOST SIMULTANEOUSLY, IN
CONCERT, BOTH CNN AND MSNBC RAN
HEADLINES ACCUSING THE
WHITE HOUSE OF WANTING TO "DUMP
IMMIGRANTS INTO CITIES."
SO WHAT'S THE MESSAGE THE LEFT
IS SENDING US, THAT IMMIGRANTS
ARE TRASH?
SOMETHING YOU DROP OFF AS A
CRUEL PRANK LIKE A FLAMING BAG
OF DOG WASTE?
IF YOU WANT TO DEFILE SOMEONE'S
PRISTINE CITY, YOU "DUMP
IMMIGRANTS ON IT?"
OH.
THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE...
SEARCHING FOR THE WORD HERE...
RACIST!
A LOT RACIST, ACTUALLY!
BUT NANCY PELOSI AGREES WITH IT,
TURNS OUT.
SHE LIVES IN ONE OF THESE CITIES
THAT MIGHT BE DUMPED ON, SO SHE
IMMEDIATELY ISSUED A STATEMENT
DECRYING IT, "THE EXTENT THIS
ADMINISTRATION CYNICISM AND
CRUELTY CANNOT BE OVERSTATED,
USING HUMAN BEINGS, INCLUDING
LITTLE CHILDREN, AS PAWNS IN
THEIR WORK CAME TO PERPETUATE
FEAR AND DEMONIZE
INDIVIDUALS IS DESPICABLE" FOR
THIS IS CONFUSING.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE SENSE
BUT HOW CAN THE PRESENCE OF
IMMIGRANTS "PERPETUATE FEAR"?
IMMIGRANTS ARE DANGEROUS FOR
THEY TOLD US THAT A THOUSAND
TIMES BUT THEY ARE SAFER THAN
YOU ARE.
THEY ARE AMAZING.
MUCH MORE AMAZING THAN YOU ARE.
POLICY SAYS THAT A LOT.
WHY IS IT BAD THAT TRUMP WANTS
US AND MORE IMMIGRANTS TO
SAN FRANCISCO.
SAN FRANCISCO IS A SECONDARY
CITY.
IT'S AVERTED FEDERAL LAW IN THE
HOPE THAT MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WOULD COME THERE,
AND THEY MAY BE COMING, BUT
SAN FRANCISCO IS UPSET.
"WELL, SAYS A NEW ANCHORS,
TRUMP'S PLAN IS ILLEGAL."
YOU CAN SEND MIGRANTS TO
AMERICAN CITIES THEY TELL US.
THERE IS A PROCESS.
IT REALLY?
THROUGH THE CITY OF LOUISVILLE,
MAINE, WHEN AN ENTIRE POPULATION
OF SOMALIS WAS MOVED FROM THE
REFUGEE CAMP TO    TO THE ALREAY
BELEAGUERED CITY.
NO.
NO PROCESS.
THE GOVERNMENT JUST DID IT.
SAME THING HAPPENED TO HALE
ATTENDING PENNSYLVANIA, OTHER
COUNTLESS PLACES ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS, THAT'S HOW
IT ALWAYS WORKS.
WHEN YOU TRY TO DO THE SAME
THING TO THE CITY WHERE
NANCY PELOSI LIVES, IT'S
SUPPOSEDLY "ILLEGAL."
THIS IS GETTING CONFUSING.
SO LET'S MAKE IT EASIER FOR
EVERYONE.
HERE'S A LIST OF NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT CAN USE SOME IMMEDIATE
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT.
THESE ARE AFFLUENT PLACES THAT
POLITICALLY LIBERAL'S MOST
AFFLUENT PLACES ARE AS A MATTER
OF POLICY AND CONVICTION.
THEY LOVE IMPOVERISHED
IMMIGRANTS FROM ABROAD OR THEY
JUST DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY YET.
LET'S CHANGE THAT.
FIRST IN LINE WOULD BE BEACON
HILL IN BOSTON.
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD HAS AN
IMMEDIATE INCOME OF UNDER
$20,000 A YEAR BEFORE
PERSPECTIVE, THAT'S DOUBLE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
IT'S STRIKINGLY
NOT DIVERSE, SO IT'LL BE GREATLY
STRENGTHENED BY THOUSANDS OF
MIGRANTS.
AS JOHN KERRY WHO LIVES IN
BEACON WILL WARNED US, FEAR OF
THE OUTSIDER, FEAR OF SOMEONE
WHO DOESN'T LOOK LIKE YOU IS AN
ATTACK ON AMERICA ITSELF.
THAT'S HEAVY.
LET'S STOP THAT ATTACK AND DO IT
BY SENDING, I DO NOT KNOW, HALF
OF THE MOST RECENT LIKE A
CARAVAN TO JOHN KERRY ZIP CODE.
HE'LL BE THRILLED.
HE'LL HAVE TO BE THRILLED.
WE'LL HEAD BACK TO THE UPPER
EAST SIDE OF NEW YORK.
FORMER MAYOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
USED TO LIVE THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM, NONE OF
THEM ACTUALLY LIVE IN HIS
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN A CITY WHERE KIDS SPEAK TO
CLOSELY 200 DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
IN THE NEW YORK CITY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, MICHAEL BLOOMBERG'S
ZIP CODE IS SHOCKINGLY LACKING
IN DIVERSITY.
LET'S CHANGE THAT, SHALL WE?
WHILE WE ARE AT IT, LET'S
INTEGRATE THAT SCHOOLS
BOTH SCHOOLS ARE FAMOUSLY AND
RIGOROUSLY PROGRESSIVE.
THEY KNOW THAT DIVERSITY IS OUR
STRENGTH.
BUT HOW MANY NEWLY ARRIVED
GUATEMALAN IMMIGRANTS HAVE THEY
ENROLLED THIS YEAR?
NOT ENOUGH.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GET THAT
NUMBER TO OVER 50% BY SEPTEMBER.
EISENHOWER DID SOMETHING VERY
SIMILAR AT CENTRAL HIGH SCHOOL
AT LITTLE ROCK IN 1956 BIT LET'S
SEE IF TRUMP CAN DO IT WITH
COLLEGIATE AND SPENDS.
THEN LET'S GO TO THE
COLLAR IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD RIGHT
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
BARACK OBAMA LIVES THERE.
AS HE PUTS IT, WE ARE A NATION
OF IMMIGRANTS.
IT ALWAYS AMERICA A BIG
ADVANTAGE OVER OTHER NATIONS.
THAT MAY BE TRUE.
YET THERE ARE VIRTUALLY NO POOR
IMMIGRANTS IN ALABAMA WHERE HE
LIVES.
LET'S IMPORT A FEW THOUSAND AND
DROP THEM IN HOW CAN OBAMA SAY
NO?
OF COURSE, HE WOULD SAY NO.
HE WOULD BE LIVID, NOBODY HATES
DIVERSITY MORE THAN RICH
LIBERALS, THE VERY PEOPLE
PUSHING IT.
LET'S HOPE IMMIGRANTS ARE
WATCHING ALL OF THIS ON TV AND
DRAWING THEIR OWN CONCLUSION.
THE LEFT CAN SAY THEY LOVE YOU.